alors cornelius le plus vieux des
éléphants 10 de sa voix tremblante mais
on s'est mis nous cherchons un endroit
pourquoi ne pas choisir babar il revient
de la ville
il a beaucoup appris chez les hommes
donnons-lui la couronne tous les
éléphants trouve que cornelius a très
bien parlé
impatients ils attendent la réponse
babar je vous remercie dit alors ce
dernier mais avant d'accepter
je dois vous dire que pendant notre
voyage en auto céleste et moins nous
nous sommes fiancés
si je suis votre roi elle sera votre
rêve vive la reine céleste vive le roi
babar qui tous les éléphants sans
hésiter mais c'est ainsi que babar d'un
roi
et
que représente pour vous la musique 10 à
la musique classique c'est la couleur le
des gens qui rêvent en couleurs hyper ex
c'est très inquiétant le plan médical
attendez je crois que la musique c'est
vivre en couleurs parce que les
mouvements sont en noir et blanc dans la
vie les gestes sont ne sont pas en
couleurs et la musique c'est la couleur
après le mariage est le couronnement
tout le monde danse bancaire
et puis c'est tout de même un moyenne
passion je trouve en entendant certaines
choses on peut être très très amoureux
de quelqu'un qui n'existe pas ou on peut
redevenir un petit enfant ou être serein
alors qu'on ne l'était pas l'instant
devant c'est un peu une drogue peut-être
je ne sais pas